yeah okay um thank you nikhil and thanks
to the uh
organizers um yeah i'm gonna talk about
some uh capacity bounds that are
different than the capacity bonds i
typically talk about
um and uh this is very
recent work with leona durbitz um and so
this this talk is not i mean that even
there should be a
more up-to-date archive post here i
don't know in the next day or two
um and so this is sort of ongoing so
that you can
keep that in the back of your mind as i
go through this
okay so here's the outline i'm going to
talk about uh
what what we what we tried to do the
main technical result
discuss uh the two main applications
or possible applications i'll talk more
about that uh
give a sense of the proof and then talk
about last some
some questions that we still have
okay okay okay so if you haven't seen
capacity uh this is what it is for the
purpose of this talk sometimes that one
that bold one there is a different
vector but for us we're just going to be
looking at the all ones
capacity so you have some polynomial
non-negative coefficients and you're
looking at this in femur over the strict
positive orthant
of the polynomial divided by this
product of the inputs
and there are a lot of applications to
certain bounds you can get on things or
approximations for things
there's a number of things you can see
the first uh the first
like oh sorry you can see the first uh
few things in the in the list are things
related to counting things on graphs
or or sort of nearby things to graphs
the second part there um is related to
metroids and doing
optimization on metroids or or counting
uh bases and metroids
um and then uh there's also been some
recent
applications to operator scaling and
invariant theory more generally with
a bunch of papers with some combination
of those authors there
uh there's probably more things on this
list that i that i haven't
written down and if i've forgotten you
you know please feel free to send me a
frustrated email and i will most
certainly
rectify that and read your paper okay
okay so i'm not going to talk too much
of these i'm just going to kind of talk
about what sort of things are needed
for these and almost always you need
some kind of log concavity condition
this is going to be
similar to the polynomials that chris
talked about the beginning of his talk
so
pretty much every application that i
know either uses real stable polynomials
or some kind of log concave polynomial
so
real stable um if you haven't seen it
it's just that
you have a polynomial with real
coefficients and whenever you plug in
entries uh which have complex part in
the upper
sorry positive imaginary part uh you
always get something that's non-zero
okay so uh when when p
is univariate it's easy to see that this
just means that
p has only real roots um and you have
this very
old result newton it says you have a
certain law concavity property of the
coefficients
of such polynomials and these are
generalized in the strong rayleigh
inequalities for
more general real stable polynomials but
you should think of this these
as sort of log concave properties and
you also have this property
uh this log and cavity in the positive
orthant okay and generalizing uh real
stable polynomials are
strongly law concave polynomials which
that term was originally coined uh by
girvitz
and his his definition was given in this
way which is you take any number of
directional derivatives in the positive
fourth
and the thing you always have at the end
is log k in the positive
um and these polynomials uh i mean as
you saw before connect are connected to
metroid's quite a bit
uh and also the jonathan yes just a
minute your volume is going
up and down very infrequent well
not continuously let me uh if i talk
like this is it
is it good maybe i'm moving closer and
away from the microphone or something
let me try that yes
maybe you should move closer because i
have to move closer is that is that
better
yeah okay okay then let me uh let me
just stay here then
um okay so so you saw
in the previous talk there's a lot of
connections to metroid's
um there's also connections like i said
to the alexander final inequalities
um volume polynomials that that
term was used in the last talk for
something specific but also
polynomials coming from volumes of
convex bodies also
have this property and also this this
property has a couple different names so
uh these two recent collections of
papers either completely log concave or
lorentzian
both of these papers approve these
masons conjectures that were talked
about previously and also
a number of other things are proven
about these polynomials there
um so this these these polynomials have
been
have been studied very you know strongly
recently
um and they have a lot of applications
okay so these are going to be the type
of polynomials we're looking at for the
most part we're just going to be looking
at real stable things but
there's also connections to these other
strongly log concave as well
okay so let's go back to to this
capacity and
we're going to interpret some things
probabilistically
and uh and then use some different kind
of
notation for things based on that so
let's say we have some polynomial p and
let's suppose that when we plug in the
all ones vector
we get one okay so that just means the
sum of the coefficients is 1
and they're all non-negative so we can
think of p
as being the generating some kind of
generating function for a probability
distribution on
its support so i'm going to think of its
support as a collection of integer
vectors
which are the sort of degree vectors for
the terms that appear in this polynomial
and the idea is that if if kappa is some
degree vector that appears then we're
going to assign probability
the corresponding coefficient to that
kappa
okay and if you think about this
probability distribution and you look at
the expectation
of it um you're basically looking at a
weighted sum of the degree
of each variable and what this boils
down to is just taking the gradient
and plugging in one so if you have some
you know
x1 cubed showing up in one term you want
to
add that to the expectation of mu 1 with
a weight of 3
because the 3 is the power and so by
taking gradient right the derivatives
pull that 3 down and give you the right
weightings
okay so i'm going to use the word
marginals to refer to this but it but it
has a you know on the left hand side you
have like the polynomial interpretation
on the right hand side you have the
probabilistic interpretation
and so another feature of capacity in
terms of
these probabilistic notions so the first
thing it's pretty straightforward to see
that capacity capacity in this case is
going to be between zero and one
okay the zero is because the
coefficients are non-negative
one because when you plug in all ones
you get one
and it's a pretty uh standard fact at
this point that
um it's going to be strictly positive if
and only if
one is in the newton polytoke of p which
is just the convex hole of the support
but the thing that's gonna be more
important to us is this fact the fact
that
it will be maximized the capacity will
be the largest value it can possibly be
whenever the marginals this expectation
here is equal
to the all ones vector
and in particular i i am probably
assuming
i might be assuming like the that there
are n variables degree n
the polynomial i i i'm going to be
assuming that throughout but just
for now we'll just say this um and i'll
say that stuff more formally later
but in this case we're going to call the
polynomial p w stochastic
okay for reasons we'll we'll see later
or maybe you already
have seen them okay so
we have this property we have some exact
value of the capacity
whenever the marginals is one but the
question that
that uh leonard and i then were looking
at is the following what happens if the
marginals are only
close to the all ones vector and the
point of this is somehow there's a
couple ways maybe to think about why you
want to ask this question
rhythmically um you know you can't
necessarily guarantee that you're going
to have some exact
knowledge of something maybe you only
have like kind of approximate knowledge
or a lot of times algorithms that that
that use capacity
are sort of iterative algorithms that
get closer and closer to something
and so you need to be able to know that
that this that this idea that
the capacity is one is sort of
continuous and we know we know that it's
continuous but we need to know we need
to know
how how continuous it is how badly can
it compass how small can the capacity
get
the further away we get from the all
ones vector for the marginals
okay so that brings us to our main
result
which is this so like i said we're
making this assumption about p
it is homogeneous it has n variables and
its degree is also equal to n
okay it has this probabilistic property
that the coefficient
sum to one we assume p is real stable
and then we have this bound on the
marginals okay it's
it only differs from the all one's
vector in one norm
uh well by by some number but that's
less than two
and when you have this you get this
lower bound on the capacity
and you can see just from the bound like
if it's if it's two or greater this
bound is
is meaningless so this bound only makes
sense for that
uh and the marginals are close to one
okay so this tells you right as you go
away from the all ones vector
this is the the most your capacity can
decrease
okay and a lot of times when you're
using capacity
we care about coefficient bounds and so
if you combine this with girvitz's
original
coefficient capacity bound which is the
left inequality here
it just says that the coefficient
corresponding to the all ones
degree vector is bounded below by
this van der waals constant times the
capacity and if you just combine these
together
you get this lower bound here for that
coefficient
you need p to have non-negative
coefficients as well right
uh yeah did i not say that yes okay that
that'll be something that i'm that i'm
assuming throughout but you are correct
yes okay
so that's that's the main result and
that's the main kind of uh
sorry coefficient corollary that we're
going to use
any questions before we move on further
than that and the assumption is that p
is real stable
yeah that's right yeah in the corollary
yeah
also in the course yeah yeah so if the
same assumptions including this
assumption that the coefficients are not
negative
okay so in fact i think if p is not
really stable this is
you can it can be a zero unless it is
equal to one
that was the point yeah so so if if if p
is not real stable if p
is just general i would assume that you
yeah you cannot get anything of this
sort i mean
you're saying something more about
whether or not like how weird the newton
polytoke can get
for a general polynomial which i'm
imagining it can get
like weird enough to where i i think you
can get
exponentially close to all ones and
still have it be outside the newton
polytopia or something i i don't know
that as much but
yeah for non-real stable this should be
this should be wrong
pretty pretty easily
okay so now we're going to talk about uh
how we can apply this to certain
situations okay so the first one is
is a matrix matrix scaling so the idea
of matrix scaling is you have some
square matrix in our case a with
non-negative entries
and we want to find some diagonal
positive matrices that we can multiply
on the left and right
uh to make a doubly stochastic which
just means that the row sums
and the column sums of a are all one so
this is the scaling
problem okay
and the idea that's typically used for
this and this has a
long history um is you have this
iterative algorithm where you
okay so i have some row sums and some
column sum so the first thing i'm going
to do is
is multiply by something to make the
rows all uh
all the row sums equal to one okay then
i need to fix the column sum so i go
over and make the column sums one
well that screws up the rows so i like
the row sums one that's because of the
columns and i keep going back and forth
like this
okay and and you know i mean in theory
this might not do anything
um you know maybe you'll just kind of go
back and forth forever but it's pretty
well known at this point that
uh pretty much this is going to converge
if and only if
your permanent is positive um and in
fact
this this type of thing was used uh for
the permanent
of a of one of these matrices in 2000
let's be able to approximate it within
an e to the n factor
okay and how do they do that well okay
the first thing to note is whenever you
multiply whenever you do this kind of
you know alternating thing
when you multiply on one side by some
diagonal matrix
the change in the permanent is just the
determinant of that diagonal matrix so
it's easy to keep track of how this is
changing the permanent over time
okay when you finally quote arrive
at a doubly stochastic matrix
uh we have this van der warden bound
okay
that tells us we have some e to the n
approximation in that case
and so now the only thing we have to
worry about is well we know we're never
going to
you know this is some this is some
sequence of events we're never going to
actually get to the doubly stochastic
thing
but we're going to get pretty close at
least in the case when
you know the permanent is positive and
so
what they use is they use some kind of
bound when the matrix is close to doubly
stochastic and this is very similar to
things that have been done in
operator scaling stuff recently but they
have this bound that says if you have
some matrix a with row sums one
and the column sums are c if you have
this two norm bound
uh of the column sums in terms of their
closeness to one
it implies some lower bound of the
permanent okay which looks very similar
to the
to our main result from the previous
slide
okay so let's see then how our bound
relates to this okay so how are we going
to apply it we're going to use this very
standard technique which is we take a
matrix a
and we turn it into this product
polynomial that's where this
productization in the title comes from
which will be talked about later
but it's referring to these product
polynomials which are products of linear
forms coming from the rows
of the matrix a so you dot each
row with a vector variables and then you
product those together
and it turns out that the all one's
coefficient of this polynomial is just
the permanent
of this original matrix okay
and now if you think about what you know
if you're looking at row sums and
columns of this matrix well the row sums
being 1
just means that if i plug in all ones
i'm just going to be getting a product
of ones
and the column sums are just exactly
equal to
the marginals this polynomial or the
associated distribution
okay so putting that all together we can
now use our bound
okay our bound is of course in terms of
the one norm but just using normal
if you can you know you can just use
normal uh inequalities between one and
two norms
to get the following so our bound then
implies that if
we have this inequality between the all
ones vector and the marginals
then we get this lower bound on the
permanent and the key improvement here
is the fact that we get this two showing
up instead of a one
um which before you just had a one in
both of these places which is a worst
bound
and of course our bound is our bound is
better if you use the one norm but this
is just showing how it
gives a chord gives something stronger
in terms of the two norm also
and like i said this is also used more
recently
for operator tensor scaling same kind of
thing you have this algorithm that
eventually you get close
and if you're close enough you need some
kind of bound like this to give
to get what you want
okay any questions about that
okay and and the other thing i'll say
here is that the the one norm bound that
we have is
is tight for real stable uh i don't know
about this two norm bound i don't know
about its tightness
um but but the one norm bound
is at least for our context okay
okay so now the the other application
which this is a little more i will say
that this it's not as clear this is a
little more i would say ongoing
thinking that's going on but i will show
you what we have here
so um this metric
traveling salesperson problem uh is you
know
the standard kind of toy version or real
version whatever you want to say is that
you have like
a bunch of cities in the country and you
have roads between them
and you're a person going around selling
things to people and you want to go to
every city
and return home and travel the least
amount of distance
okay and this is one of these classic uh
np-hard problems oh and by the way this
metric word just means that the triangle
inequality holds that's what it means
this is one of these classic npr
problems uh and even approximation
within
a small factor is is np hard okay
but um in the 70s an approximation
uh algorithm with approximation factor
three halves was given um and i'm not
gonna
i'm just gonna very kind of hand wave
all this that the general algorithm is
that you
first pick a minimum spanning tree
spanning tree of minimum weight
and then you add sort of a minimum
weight matching on
the odd degree vertices of the tree and
you put these two together
and you get this path that this sales
person is going to take
and very recent work which we're going
to hear about on friday
has improved this factor to something
slightly lower
than three halves okay and the and the
the main change from what i can gather
is that the
that instead of doing the minimum
spanning tree you have this random
spinning tree based on
this linear relaxation so instead of
thinking
of spanning trees as you can think of
them as lattice points and you can
take their convex hole you have this
polytope and you do
some kind of optimization problem over
that polytope and then you
get a distribution on the spanning trees
and you randomly select one so this is a
randomized algorithm
but uh using that change you can improve
this factor
and that factor may look you know small
the improvement but this is the first
general improvement
to my knowledge of this of this problem
so there have been a lot of there are a
lot of
been a lot of things done in special
cases but in terms of improving this
algorithm from
40 or 50 years ago this is the first
time in general that this was able to be
done
and like i said i i i will admit my
knowledge on this on this uh
improvement and and the problem is is
not very big uh and so you should
definitely
listen to the talk on friday that's
actually about this improvement but i'm
just gonna now
shift gears to connections to to our
bound
okay so i'm going to start from a place
that that's
that where our bounds starts to become
important in their paper
okay so we're going to have some
distribution on on the
power set of one through m so we're
picking some random subset
of one through m and to this
distribution we're gonna sort of do the
reverse thing that we did before right
we had a polynomial we made it into a
distribution we're gonna we're gonna do
the reverse thing and so
we're going to come up we're going to
have this polynomial q which we're going
to sum over all possible subsets
and the coefficient for that subset is
just going to be the probability of that
subset
and the term will be this y to the s
just means
product together all the variables that
that
come from s okay so this is not
homogeneous
um and so that's going to be something
we're going to have to try to deal with
okay we have this polynomial okay
and one example that's particularly
pertinent to this situation
is if for instance you let your set one
through m be the edges of some graph
you look at the uniform distribution on
spanning trees and make a polynomial out
of that
you get something real stable and in
fact also you can
have your probabilities be according to
um like you can add some extra factor
that products together positive
constants of edges from the tree
so so there's some kind of tweak you can
do of just the uniform distribution and
you also get something real stable
and there are you know a huge number of
examples for this these are the two i'm
going to point out
because of their relation to this
situation
okay and now the other thing we're going
to do is and this is this is where
they start to need to do something like
our bound
we're going to if you pick disjoint sets
that who's whose
union is the whole of m we're going to
make these
new random variables which are summing
the underlying distribution random
variables from
each subset and what this means is if
you pick some random x
from 1 through m according to new
then the random variable a i is just
counting the number of elements of x
that come from s i
okay and with this this comes to the
main
line of their paper that we are going to
investigate
which is this so when q is real stable
they show that when you have some bound
on the expectation of this of these ais
it gives some bound on the probability
that those ais are all ones
okay and they get some lower bound that
is doubly exponential in n
but has no which n again was the number
of subsets
that we broke the s1 through sn and
m was the number of elements in our
ground set at the beginning okay
so what we're going to do now which is
what we did before is we're going to
translate this into a
pollen a more polynomial statement that
we can do something with
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is we take our polynomial q
and for every for every fixed set s i
we look at all the js within si and all
of those variables we just set to the
same variable
x i so somehow this is taking
all the variables according to each of
these s-i sets and just turning them
into a single variable
and when you do this right well this is
now going to drop this p
tilde now has just n variables according
to the
subsets um the degrees are the same
okay and now the marginals of this new
polynomial
are exactly the expectation of a in fact
the distribution corresponding to p
tilde like we saw at the beginning of
the talk is just
a one through a n so somehow we've
constructed a polynomial
that is associated directly to this
random variable
a so we have that our marginals
are what we would want them to be this
expectation and now the all one's
coefficient
again because this is associated to this
distribution a
is just the probability that a is the
all one's vector
okay so if we then translate this
statement into language closer to
something we can work with it's just
this
so they show that when this polynomial
is real stable
if your marginals are close to all ones
then you get a lower bound on this
coefficient which is exactly the sort of
thing we can do
okay so let's see then what we get
okay so here's our bound we proved that
we showed before
okay how can we apply this so this is
the thing we actually want this is the
thing they show
and there are a few problems so the
first problem is
p tilde isn't homogeneous and it's its
number of variables is
is a lot lower than its potential total
degree so we need to do some kind of
transformation to line that all up
and there's a way you can do this you
can homogenize and kind of
add a lot of variables like a sum of
variables in that in that extra
homogenous variable and
there's some transformations you can do
to get to the situation
so that we can apply this and the other
thing we have to deal with is the fact
that our bound has this two and somehow
theirs is this one minus epsilon but
that also comes out in the
homogenization you add this extra
variable
that sort of takes one of the you know
it drops two to one
somehow so this all works we can all put
this together
and the thing we eventually get is this
okay we get this lower bound on the
coefficient
but the problem with this is that
d at least a priori could be equal to m
right and we wanted to avoid dependence
on m
which we could not so in some cases when
d is
is small or close to n this
this of course improves upon the doubly
exponential but uh
again i i'm a little i don't exactly
know this is still kind of work in
progress
um i i don't know how actually
applicable that is i'm assuming
not very um but the thought is that
probably if we sort of rework this whole
thing from
a different perspective where instead of
starting off with
degree n homogenous and variables we
sort of started off with with their
um starting case the hope would be that
these arguments would lead to better
bounds
and this is kind of what happens in
girvin's original capacity bound if
you're familiar
his original bound was for this exact
type of situation
homogeneous degree equals number of
variables but it turns out actually you
can generalize this to non-homogenous
thing
uh non-homogenous polynomials and the
bound still only depends on
the number of variables which is exactly
the sort of thing we want here so
this is the kind of like open part
we we we don't we don't know but our
everything we have so far is before we
make this application is tight
can we tweak things to make this work uh
currently
unclear um but that that is
that is uh yeah that's so that's kind of
what we're what we're doing here so
that's the end of the discussion of that
um it's unfortunate that the
metric tsp talk didn't come before this
because i think it's maybe pretty clear
that
you know i haven't really fully grocked
uh what's going on in that paper
um and so i just sort of stuck to what i
knew
but anyway so any any questions before i
before i move on
okay so there's just a few minutes left
maybe like three or four depending on
maybe three or whatever whenever we
started a little bit late
um so let me just quickly talk a little
bit about the proof
okay so
the proof outline is gonna go like this
so we talked about these product
polynomials you have some
non-negative entry matrix a that's just
a product of linear forms like this
uh we're always going to assume the row
sums are one which means that p of one
equals one and when the columns under
alpha we're going to use this notation
the p a
comes from this space product and
alpha okay and the column sounds like
you saw before exactly the marginals of
this polynomial
okay so there are two theorems that come
together to make this work the first one
is
we prove our bound for product
polynomials so this is just a rewording
of the original bound just not for real
stable
for product polynomials okay
and then the way that we're going to put
this all together is we're going to
prove this productization result
okay so if you have one of these
polynomials p that's real stable and has
all the
various properties that we that we
usually are assuming
and you fix any x in the strict positive
orthant and we can always find some
product polynomial with the same
marginals such that these polynomials
coincide at this point
okay and in a sense at least
to me sometimes when i look at this it
feels innocuous like oh okay we just
need to get these things to agree at one
point
find some polynomial that makes them
agree at one point
but the thing is this essentially once
you have this bound for product
polynomials
being able to do this sort of thing this
productization result
gives you the bound for whatever class
of polynomials you can do this for
and we know that this bound shouldn't be
true in general so this is definitely
not going to be true for general
polynomials
real stability crucially comes into play
to make this happen
um so pa is a function of x here right
pa is is this polynomial yeah sorry a is
yes correct
yes yes you are correct uh for every x
there is a pa yeah
so that that's the thing that makes this
feel innocuous at least to me
because once you pick the x you can pick
any polynomial to make this work
but if you think about the reason why
this is going to give you the bound for
real stable is because if you think
about what this min
of capacity is up here you can just
think of that as an inf of an inf
of some expression and so you can take
the inner imp and move it out
and now once you move the inner info
which is inf over x greater than zero
you can just fix one show that the inner
if
you can change from product to real
stable and then switch them again
so this productization result is exactly
the sort of thing you need to be able to
generalize this product polynomial bound
to any class if you can get this for any
class
then then you you get the bound for that
class
okay and i don't have
too much time it looks like so let me
just show you these next few
proof slides just just to sort of give
you a sense of what's going on
so the main limit for this so this is
proving the the bound for product
polynomials
essentially we show that we kind of show
like a weaker version of our bound which
is that this condition on the
this this condition one in the lemma
which is the the bound that we need to
assume
uh to get our lower bound implies that
the that the min capacity
is positive so this is like a you know
we get an actual lower bound in the
result so this is kind of a first step
um and that's equivalent to the
permanent also being positive
and essentially the idea of the proof if
you look at this is that you kind of
subtract off the lowest
the kind of the biggest doubly
stochastic matrix you can
this enforces that the permanent has to
be zero that allows you to get some
bound on the column sums
according to this lemma and then because
we know capacity of double stochastic
matrices
is easy this then gives you some lower
bound on the original matrix so that's a
very hand wavy
argument it's it's sort of given a
little more detail there
and this condition 3 in the lemma is not
really useful uh
at least for this argument um but i put
it there because it has this kind of
reminiscence to the to the
you know the hall condition um and so i
thought that would be it's kind of
interesting that it appears here as well
and then the last part is the
productization part and the main lemma
for that is due to petter
okay and the idea is that
you take one of these polynomials p we
care about you say that its marginals
are already all ones vectors so it's
doubly stochastic as a polynomial
you look at the roots in some direction
and you always get that the input vector
majorizes the roots of that linear
restriction
and if you the majorization relation
gives you a doubly stochastic matrix
right it says that there's a doubly
stochastic matrix d such that dx
equals lambda x and then you can kind of
do some
algebra and some perturbation argument
to route this
in to get kind of
you can i guess you can just make this
work for not just uh
all ones marginals so you first do it
for rational you do some
transformation like this it turns it
into doubly stochastic you use the lemma
and then you sort of sum blocks together
and then
once you have everything rational you
use some perturbation argument to get
irrational
alpha okay so i i
spent less time on these last two slides
than i would have liked to but it is
what it is um
okay and then the open questions are
mainly okay right you know i sort of
showed how you could route this to get
to try to get something kind of improved
to get bound for this tsp uh inequality
it doesn't really improve it in the way
that we'd hoped but
but the but we do think that if you sort
of start off with the right context
the the ideas should help to get
something better
um another question is can you extend
these as strong log and k polynomials so
the this lemma of
brenden that we use required right it
sort of
inherently requires on requires roots
which you know which you don't have
in the strongly law concave case um
is there some other argument that would
make this work and also like i said
this is very new uh we had some
applications in mind when we were
writing this
but are there other applications of this
that we haven't thought of
and that's it
question
so i mean i think naturally it should
generalize but
uh you should be able to extend to any
integer vector right not just
all one vector uh yeah okay
yeah and i think i think that that's
also true
um we haven't thought too much about
that but i would be surprised if that
didn't work
um you mean like integer vector and also
change the capacity vector to be that
integer vector
yeah yeah i think that i think that that
should i think that that should work uh
i mean we haven't i don't think we've
explicitly thought about it but
yeah so i agree that that should work
um and and you could say that like when
you homogenize
you know you you then want to look at
this vector of all ones with an extra
like
big factor but i think even if you do
the naive thing
and just extend our result to integer
vectors
i i still think that what you end up
getting
um for the lower bound still depends on
d
which at least again i you know maybe we
can talk about this offline or
something but you know uh this
dependence on the degree of the
polynomial seems
to to have to be there i know that
that's that's not true in some of
griffith's results so
you know maybe it doesn't but i still
don't exactly know
how that depends on the degree how how
how necessary that is we don't know
i have a basic question okay
so uh if you fix the marginals and look
at the positive and you fix the x and
you look at the possible values of p
of x is that a convex set is that an
interval
well so i think that that that at least
in the case that we look at
so um let's see so i think that that has
to be true
by uh okay well maybe it doesn't yeah no
no i think it has to be true by that
productization result because i think in
the productization case
you're looking at some sort of
projection of
like the set of all matrices with row
sums one and column sums
like fixed and so i think
there you you for product polynomials
you get what you just said that this is
an interval
and so if that's if that's true then
then it also extends to real stable
polynomials
um but but there may be some easier
argument for this that i'm just not
thinking of
um it seems like it should be an
interval in general but i i'm not i'm
not sure